الثالث ملكا اطلالات خلاقه وجنونيه في
ميدجال 2023 المتحف القومي للحضارات يرحب
بباك ستريت بويز ويتبرا من حفل اصاله
وليله روائع الموجي في الرياض اليكم
الابرز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
باطلالات مستوحاه من اشهر تصاميمه على مدى
عقود وكان هناك الكثير من الاطلالات
الخلاقه والخارج عن المالوف تكريما لقطه
المصمم الراحل الشهيره ايضا
ومن العالم الى مصر التي عبرت فرقه
باكستريد بويز الشهيره عن سعادتها
بزيارتها واحياء حفل بالقاهره الاسبوع
الماضي كجزء من جولتها الغنائيه التي تشمل
دولا في افريقيا والشرق الاوسط والهند
ونشر المتحف القومي للحضاره المصريه صورا
من زياره الفرقه الى المتحف
المتحف القومي للحضاره المصريه نوعها في
وقت سابق من الاسبوع الماضي الى ان حفل
اصاله لم يكن سيقام في المتحف وانما في
بحيره القاهره الملاصقه له والتي لا تخضع
لسلطه المتحف باي شكل من الاشكال وذلك في
تعليق من المتحف على حفل اعلنت اصاله انها
ستحييه فيه قبل ان تشير بوضوح الى مكان
الحفل وهو بحيره عين الصيره وذلك في عقاب
حمله كبيره وجهت ضدها من متابعين مصريين
على منصات التواصل دعت الغاء الحفل الذي
اقيم في موعده المحدد من تنظيم ابنها خالد
وسط استمرار الحمله ضدها
ليله دي فرحه وبس حب وغنى مزيكا ورقص ووقف
الى جانبها الفنان رامي صبري الذي غرد عبر
حسابه الرسمي على تويتر مخاطبا اصاله انت
مصر وانت الوطن العربي وانت تقولي شبر من
ارضنا العربيه نحبك ونحترم وجودك وسطنا
ونشر لاحقا صوره الى جانبها من الحفل
اعتبرها اكبر من الرد على الكلام الصغير
بحسب تعبيره
ومن مصر الى السعوديه وليله روائع الموجي
التي اقيمت في الرياض تكريما للموسيقار
الراحل محمد الموجي الليله التي حققت
تفاعلا كبيرا على منصات التواصل شارك فيها
نخبه من نجوم الغناء في العالم العربي
وغاب عنها وائل جسار في اللحظات الاخيره
بسبب وعكه صحيه تعرض لها واطل المغني
اللبناني في فيديو عبر حسابه الرسمي على
انستجرام بدا فيه شديد الاعياء متوجها
بالشكر لتركي ال الشيخ على تفهمه لما حدث
معه اعاده صحي
طلع ضغطي
كتير
الشديد
اشكر كل الناس
يساعدوا عني